foreign
[Music]
Godzilla we are now in an era where we
will see three Godzilla flicks within a
span of a year but enough about that
Touhou has officially announced and
released the first Godzilla teaser right
after that timeline countdown from the
most recent Touhou Godzilla movie which
is shin Gojira of 2016 all the way
through the Millennium era movies with
final wars Tokyo SOS and all that seen
in the background then faster with the
heisei era seeing glimpses of Godzilla
vs destoroya Space Godzilla Mecca King
Ghidorah against Mothra and fast
forwarding the show error slowing in the
original and then ending with zero but
then we hear Godzilla's footsteps and
the number zero starts changing to -0.1
minus 0.2 going back with the negative
scale until -1 as the end of the
countdown
then they released the actual teaser and
it begins with a backdrop sounds of the
footsteps of the G-Man and captions
which reads post-war Japan had lost
everything now this for those who don't
know is set right after World War II
hence the world both war Japan losing
the war against the United States and
her allies ending with the atomic bombs
being dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
it is not known as to what city that is
which is shown in the teaser but it is
definitely the backdrop of either new
cities or another one which is utterly
destroyed as a result of carpet bombing
during the war now this seems to tell us
that the devastation has awakened the
king of the monsters
now the next scene clears the doubt here
we see a landscape that is in rubble
smoke from the aftermath everywhere and
a large crater in the middle which means
yes it is the site of an atomic bombing
well this would be said a few days or a
few weeks after the explosions but the
destruction is still fresh relatively
captions read that the movie is written
and directed by Takashi yamazaki who
directed the movie sunset on 3rd Street
which had a cameo of Godzilla in it
albeit in a dream sequence where the
Kaiju destroys buildings in Japan even
though he hasn't really directed a
Godzilla movie in the past I would count
Sunset as a bit of an experience and
also he does have quite a portfolio
anyway in another pose it states that it
is set in both war Japan Godzilla minus
one will once again show us a Godzilla
that is terrifying and overwhelming foes
the concept that is Japan which had
already been devastated by the war faces
a new threats with Godzilla bringing the
country into the miners so essentially
the countdown means that we would
obviously be going back to the beginning
with time being a factor in the movie
this will definitely be a reboot of the
original and will tell the tale from a
different angle hopefully we will have a
proper backstory in the history of the
king of the monsters kick-starting a new
beginning and Paving way for a new era
of the G-Man side by side with a monster
verse the next scene shows a city in
Ruins and that's basically that then
right after that we see captions reading
from zero to minus indicating that even
after losing a wall and falling down so
far as to be back in the beginning zero
Godzilla will Rampage across the
remnants and take the country even
further down hence zero to minus one
then immediately we see what seems to be
Godzilla's tail swiping an entire city
block with a rubble flying around as
people panic screaming and running in
all directions we then see a carriage or
part of a train being thrown across like
it weighed nothing this takes us back to
the 1954 original where Godzilla grabs a
train and starts munching on it we then
see further chaos in Split scenes and
then Godzilla's feet stomping the ground
creating chaos with hundreds of people
in the foreground running all around
this by the looks of it would be in
another city in Japan therefore this
Godzilla wouldn't be like Shin Shin
Gojira who is stuck in Tokyo
Godzilla minus will have him rampaging
all across the post-war country
the scene then ends with a black and
white symbol or logo of the movie and a
voice saying Gojira minus one and then
right after that we see our new
Godzilla's face reliving his past about
to have a Milky Way train bar snack so
this movie is in post-production as of
now and will be released in November 3rd
in Japan and then on December 1st in the
United States there are leaks and
theories that this one will share a
continuity with Shin Gojira of 2016 and
have strong elements of horror as
originally intended this one which I
don't really think it would be true
since the World building for connecting
these two dots these two stories minus
what occurring in post-war Japan and
shin in 2016 would be too much of a pain
in the butt so right after this video we
will do another one focusing on the
design and the size of this new
um renewed original Godzilla
anyway I hope you have enjoyed watching
this video do hit the like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
and new videos right here on this
channel especially the next video on the
size and design of this new Godzilla
from minus one so take care fam